the mule is currently making its way
through theaters and while it is
underperforming slightly at the cinema
that doesn't mean that there's no merit
to the film throughout this video I'll
be breaking down everything that you
need to know about the movie as well as
the real-life inspiration behind it
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know the
film's ending all plot details and I
highly suggest that you turn off now
there everyone else
I'm definition and welcome to the
channel where I roon it so you don't
have to do the mule follows Earl stone
played by Clint Eastwood Hill is a 90
year old Korean War veteran who's on the
edge of complete financial ruin to top
this all off his family want very little
to do with him a tutor than the Glock
that they faced from Earl over the years
basically Earl is a hard-ass with a
stiff upper lip that feels like the kind
of character Clint Eastwood was born to
play
Earl is based on the real-life World War
two veteran Leo sharp who was known to
his cartel handlers as al Tata
similar to Al Leo was a horticulturalist
who began his career on the wrong side
of the law shipping cash on behalf of
the cartel Leo quickly elevated to
narcotics and was a very reliable member
of staff Leo used a pickup truck to
transport up to 300 kilograms of cocaine
at a time from the southern US border to
Detroit similar to this we watch Earl
doing drug runs as a mule for the cartel
and he quickly Rises through the ranks
due to his dependency though the film
shifts the truth slightly with stone
being a veteran of the Korean War where
a sharp was the second world war they
are still very similar in ideology stone
and Sharpe both saw the money as ways to
right the wrongs of their past and I
love how Earl uses the cash that he
accumulates in a sort of Robin Hood
manner to fix his past ill renovators
VFW Post and pays for his
granddaughter's wedding both of which he
would have been unable to do so without
the trade that he worked in what the
film does expertly is that it reflects
the flaws in the American Dream bill
worked his entire life even sacrificing
major events from it in order to
continue his work for material goals
this forces him to still be working at
90 with little to show for it
his family hate him for it and he has no
real relationships that
anymore very little in his life has a
purpose apart from running drugs similar
to this Clint Eastwood himself has often
sacrificed elements of his life in order
to pursue his career in filmmaking even
though he is approaching 90 Eastwood is
still working and whilst he is cemented
as a legend one has to wonder at what
cost there's a real autobiographical
sense to the piece that definitely makes
it stand out what defines the film is
not Earl's lack of respect for authority
but rather his complete rejection of it
the DEA similar to the cartel is
depicted as an operation that cares
little for its employees and Bradley
Cooper does a fascinating job of
realizing that he and Earl are not too
dissimilar like Leo L becomes trapped in
a web that he cannot escape from and the
DEA close in on the character by the
film's finale by the end Earl is
arrested and put on trial the man pleads
guilty in court and is sentenced a
federal prison
mirroring this Leo was arrested and
eventually confined to prison however
due to declining health after one year
he was set free Leo Sharpe died in
December 2016 at the age of 92 Sharpe
may have been showcased as a hero but a
lot of lives were ruined due to the
career path he chose the mule itself is
a depiction of how life doesn't tend to
end all guns blazing but rather with a
whimper the fact that the movie is under
performing at the box office is poetic
in itself but I highly recommend that
you check it out as it's definitely a
fitting farewell for an actor of
Eastwood stature so what are your
thoughts on the mule did you enjoy it
and what did you take from the film
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please like it
and check out my breakdown of this
week's other big movie Aquaman this is a
channel for people who are mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
you
[Music]